a new trailer for the Japanese arcade  version of Tekken 7 hats or wheels that  street fighters Akuma will be joining  the ranks of the existing tekken  combatants the japanese trailer shows  off some of the characters backstory as  well as the kumas new but familiar moves  in tekken 7 the new addition is arriving  as part of an arcade update called fated  retribution no release date for the  update has been announced as yet but it  is set to bring more graphical updates  as well as brand new content second 7 is  also in development for PlayStation 4  although it is currently only scheduled  to launch in Japan interestingly Akuma  has not been announced as part of the  street fighter 5 roster let me know if  you're an Akuma fan and we'll keep you  updated on this news and everything else  that matters in gaming on gamespot